on oublie quelque chose parce que
j'écoute là depuis tout à l'heure mais
on oublie l'essentiel dans tout ça c'est
à dire on oublie le carburant qui
alimente cetero ce terrorisme là c'est à
dire le terrorisme islamiste parce qu'il
faut encore le nommer ce n'est pas le
terrorisme le terrorisme
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas c'est ce n'est
pas un moyen d'imposer quelque chose de
terrorisme s'est il est bien précis il
ya utero il ya eu le terrorisme base qui
a eu le terrorisme de letea et le
terrorisme on ira en angleterre je viens
en angleterre ils en sont encore il en
soit encore marqué et aujourd'hui fin
aujourd'hui non depuis de nombreuses
années il ya l'islamisme qui veut
prendre le pas sur une partie de ski
d'occident en 1924 qui a été créée là la
confrérie des frères musulmans et les
frères mais dans les faits dans la dans
la doctrine dans la vie dans le texte
fondateur des frères musulmans c'est
d'une part de redonner dirais-je de
redonner la grandeur aux musulmans ceux
qui avaient une partie des musulmans
surtout les sionistes ceux qui étaient
ceux qui avaient on va dire le califat
avant 1924 et et aussi essayer
d'instaurer sur la sueur sur le sur le
reste du globe
un islam que leur islam donc c'est déjà
premièrement c'est une erreur de dire
que ce sont pas des musulmans ce sont
des musulmans parce que je les ai
côtoyés de près mois en libye je laisser
ces gens là dedans qui se dé groupes
islamistes sont musulmans
les 19 salles attentats de nice je suis
désolé mais on l'a retrouvé en boîte de
nuit il buvait l'alcoolisme et vous
allez dire que finalement c'est le
musulman mais quelle définition et c'est
d'être musulman attendait mais très
dangereux de dire ce genre de choses
c'est pas dangereux du tout ce qui est
dangereux c'est pas musulman ce qui est
dangereux des lancers le théorisé ce qui
est dangereux mais au lieu d'être dans
le déni permanent comme l'a fait
non absolument dangereux entièrement une
réalité je vais répondre aux dernières
victimes d islam mission de ce sens les
mises en bourse suisse
ce sont les musulmans qui tue tout ce
qui ne leur hausse à nice
ces listes ne leur ressemblent pas ça a
commencé par les musulmans qui ne leur
semble pas cessation ne sais pas ça le
début de l'émission vous avez pris que 3
fois la parole laissez moi finir pour la
première fois on a un technicien qui
nous parle de son expérience ou venez de
l'intérêt que vous étiez là beaucoup
changé syrie reste là non mais là il
était mieux avant je termine parce que
ce que l'organisme compte mon côté de la
plaque est donc mais c'est ça fait pas
sens fait partie parce que c'est pour en
arriver justement à quelqu'un comme vous
comme vous le décrivez c'est certain
c'est quelqu'un qui est malléable
intellectuellement qui est fragile
psychologiquement
donc cette personne là va être au bout
de la chaîne et va servir de chair à
canon
on en trouve dans toutes les armées du
monde les mecs en bas de l'échelle ont
toutes les armées américaine française
polonaise en bas de l'échelle
ils n'ont pas inventé l'eau chaude mais
il en faut donc les donneurs d'ordre ce
sont des gens qui sont un peu plus
éduqués des médecins aussi qui acquit à
qui adhèrent à ce projet parce que moi
je parle d'un projet à venir